they'll be facing brad keller who's
coming off his best start of the season
three starts he is one and one
[Applause]
and the fastball is lined into right
there's a base hit on a no two pitch
and meadows is a board to start this
game tonight
the 60-game season ground ball that's
through the right side back-to-back
singles
meadows
advances on the base hit to right so the
rays
have a threat right here in the first
and now ahead of wendell and he chops it
to the left side and alberto got a bit
tangled up
with meadows going second to third i'm
not sure that was a double play ground
ball anyway so lao with the advantage in
the count
[Applause]
on the ground second base a bobble run
is going to score
everybody is going to be safe grace took
advantage of some miscues last night and
they get a run in the first inning
and now lifted to center taylor's there
wendell goes to tag but he's not going
anywhere
so manuel margot
is out on one pitch and there are two
down
back to the middle
and that's alberto with the shift
for the tampa bay rays it will be
left-hander rich hill making his fourth
start of the season perfect record of
one and oh 14 and third innings of work
and those are the ones that drive you
crazy and you know they drive him crazy
and a
slow curve
tap right back to the mound so he gets a
good hitter in maryfield
but the last time he faced him was in
april
of 2016.
wendell at third will handle this one a
couple ground ball outs
the four-seam fastball and the curveball
took center stage
on the ground to third off a breaking
ball
wendell takes care of that three ground
ball outs three up three down ace has
loaded nobody out you have got to look
at this as guys we need a big inning
let's bury them early here we go
and a high fly ball to right field
dozier
sets up to make the catch the tag
karemeyer is going to score
easily from third and the rays get their
second round of the night
got him with a fastball
so keller puts a hitter away
well it's up to joey wendell if the rays
are to pick up anything else 2-2
fastball in and that's going to drop a
looper into left
so wendell gets the run home adama's
crossing the plate
royal pitcher here in the early going
not having a good feel for it
and he misses by plenty
right there
and the rays will pick up another run
zadino trouts down the line from third
so the walk
and there's another walk
so he lost him after getting ahead in
the count and that will force wendell
home
and the rays make it a five-run ball
game now
and now the royals have a chance to get
right back in this game with runners in
scoring position and nobody out
line base hit right field
then in tendy scores
here comes taylor and now it's 5-2 with
nobody out
good situation here for santana it's
just what he wants
and santana cranks it to left field and
that's going to be up against the wall
it is a one-run game as the royals have
scored four in the third
and now the tying run is in scoring
position with nobody out brings up
brandon lau
wow shoots it into center field taylor
going back he's looking up and that
baby's out of here
home run to center brandon lau
on the first pitch of the at-bat
and the rays pick up another run
to make it a two-run ball game
[Applause]
fastball and a shot towards second wow
nice play
to throw out dozier
ray's defender how about brandon lau to
his left glove side makes that look
pretty easy
so runner it's second one down that
brings up willy adams
[Applause]
nice shot back into center on the run
it's taylor still going to the track he
leaps and it's going to be off the wall
keermeyer grounding third on his way to
the plate and the rays pick up another
run
now they're up by three carlos santana
hits it high and deep right center field
kier meyer is back
leaping it is gone and carlos santana
has driven in three tonight
and the royals will not go away
and the bases are loaded now margot the
batter here's the pitch swing ground
ball to short
and by mickey lopez into left field two
runs will score
and the runners are going to advance on
a missed throw and tampa bay goes up
nine to five
broken down on the fastball popped into
shadow center that's going to drop
loud's going to score margot follows
across the plate on the looping base
head for satsugo
the rays make it a four-run inning
back to the middle
that's worth a
two liter of pepsi products nikki lopez
scores
it is 11-6 in the sixth inning
hunter dozier
will pick up an rbi lao throws him out
alberto scores it is 11-7 one-on-one out
and here is mike zenino
there's a drive this one well tagged and
that one is going to get out of here
long home run to left by mike zenino
his third home run of the year
and he drives in two with a blast to
make it 13-7
now there's a drive back into right
field dozier's going to go to the wall
and this one is going to get out back to
back zanino and meadows here in the
ninth inning
there's a wave and a
on strikes
and the popper
right side
wow short right field out for the second
to make the catch and the rays win it
it's a 14-7 victory for the rays tonight